there was a period of time
where you were popping up on a lot of
june at radio [ __ ] the mixtapes back in
the day was there ever uh any
conversations where 50 was trying to
assign you to g unit man me and 50 we
talked about doing some business um a
few times um it never like happened like
i think mainly due to like scheduling
this stuff but we didn't specifically
talk like on signing to because see
no matter
if i'm on tv or not like i'm i came in
this industry as a ceo so if i would
ever do a deal with another artist it
would be a joint partnership it would be
a partnership i'll never ever be under
anybody
and never have uh every album i ever put
out i was the ceo so i was already
taught as a kid come in a game of ceo be
a artist don't let people tell you oh
you should just focus on
the music part and let us talk for you
and know that's how you get robbed
that's how lawyers put that's how you
get those shitty deals bro that's how
lawyers man finesse you out of breathe
especially the lawyers that like are
suggested to you by the people you're
signing to oh you don't have a good
lawyer we got one for you yeah bro
they're [ __ ]
so
i'mma talk for myself i get to done
i get the deal done way quicker when i
talk for myself did you ever have a
situation where you got into a shitty
deal like early on like whether it was
the sony or the warner situation because
back in the day those major label deals
were [ __ ] treacherous thank god i
never got into a shitty deal i've been
in some deals where
i got what i wanted i got what i asked
for but
i looked out for somebody out of what i
got right only to find out later that
they had got
a separate bag for themselves as well so
they dipped in they double dipped they
double dip but i still got what i want
because at the end of the day i think
like a hustler
i get paid to talk
sing make words rhyme come up with witty
[ __ ] make a [ __ ] say wow
it's people that talk all day they don't
that don't get paid for so i look at it
like this bruh
any amount of money that a [ __ ]
go pay me just a talk is a win
now when we go to my accolades and what
i've accomplished i know how to find a
medium of
i know how to negotiate my dad was a
master car salesman so i know how to
play a sheep i know how to play a wolf
because at the end of the day i'm a
hustler so
at the end of the day almost any amount
of money that's respectful respectable
it's not getting [ __ ] over you see
what i'm saying but yeah i've always
known how to speak my mind because i
grew up around older people i'm i'm the
youngest in the screwed up clique but
i'm not afraid to speak my mind if og or
somebody did something to me that i feel
like they slighted me and it was wrong
i'm gonna address it now i know how to
approach it respectful you see what i'm
saying i'm not i'm not a reckless you
know g you know [ __ ] like that but
i'm not afraid to speak my mind and i'm
a very honorable person